what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel and today i have
another episode of showing feminists
jordan peterson
um today i have a special guest on the
channel i have natasha hi guys
and you said you're like a maybe
feminist yeah you know i'm not gonna lie
maybe you know it is yeah
i'm not gonna lie you lost my fine it's
funny but it's just the thing was just
like
what is an actual feminist that's what i
want to know that's why i'm a maybe
feminist because i want to know what's
the actual definition of a feminist but
you know what so okay yeah so i'm gonna
tell you just full disclosure right yeah
i think feminism is evil i think it's
toxic i think they want equality but i
don't think equal like nothing's ever
going to be equal you know
like i think that men and women like
we're not equal we're not the same and i
think they're trying to make us the same
and so one of the things that you
brought up you weren't sure why men and
women make different like money yeah
right and you didn't really understand
that right yeah
because it's just a thing where it's
just like you know the phrase so like
for a woman that makes 75 cents yeah um
my men make a dollar
and it's just like why just can't we get
paid the same type of thing for doing
the same job
that's what i believe like if you're
going to do that for example let's take
something like physiotherapy just for
example just put it out there if you're
making a certain amount why can i not
make the same um why can't i not make
the same amount but it's a thing where
it's like because of my gender i get
paid less that's something it's like so
so this is this guy is a psychologist so
i'm going to show you and he has studied
the pay gap and he's going to give you
some information that might change your
perspective a little bit all right then
that's cool that's cool yeah so this is
jordan peterson
jordan peterson you've said that men
need to quote grow the hell up tell me
why
well because there's nothing
uglier than an old infant
there's nothing good about it
people who don't grow up don't find the
sort of meaning in their life that
sustains them through difficult times
and they're certain to encounter
difficult times
and they're left bitter and resentful
and without purpose and adrift and
hostile and resentful and vengeful and
arrogant and deceitful and and of no use
to themselves and of no use to anyone
else and no partner for a woman and
there's nothing in it that's good so i
mean that sounds pretty bad you're
saying the crisis of masculinity i mean
what do you do about it you
tell
you help people understand why
it's necessary and important for them to
grow up and adopt responsibility why
that isn't a shake your finger and get
your act together sort of thing why it's
more like but why it's more like
a delineation of the kind of destiny
that makes life worth living i've been
telling young men and but it's not i
wasn't specifically aiming this message
at young men to begin with it just kind
of turned out that way and it's mostly
you admit it's mostly men listening i
mean it is then your audience is amazing
well it's about 80 on in on youtube
which is a
youtube is a male domain primarily so
it's hard to tell how much of it is
because youtube is male and how how much
of it is because of what i'm saying
but um
you you what i've been telling young men
is that there's an actual reason why
they need to grow up which is that they
have something to offer you know that
that
that people have within them this
capacity to set the world straight and
that's necessary to manifest in the
world and that also doing so is where
you find the meaning that sustains you
in life so what's gone wrong then
oh god all sorts of things have gone
wrong i think that
i don't think that young men are
hear words of encouragement some some of
them never in their entire lives as far
as i can tell that's what they tell me
and the fact that the words that i've
been that i've been speaking the youtube
lectures that i've done and put online
for example have had such a dramatic
impact is an indication that
young men are starving for this sort of
message because like why in the world
would they have to derive it from a
lecture on youtube
now they're not being taught that they
so question
have you ever heard girls say something
like men are trash men are the worst oh
yeah
yes i have do you do you think it would
be okay if men would constantly say
women are [ __ ]
no
why do you think that is
like where we have the right to like
criticize them beyond all means but if
they criticize us
it's like hell has frozen over okay
when it comes to stuff like that
you know what you said i've got like you
so hold on i'm asking you yeah men are
trash woman or [ __ ] is that what
you're saying
no i what i'm saying what you just said
what i'm saying is that i think that men
women are allowed to criticize men but
men are not allowed to criticize women
okay
like i think if men walked around saying
women are [ __ ] the same way women will
say men are trash
because why do they usually say that
it's usually because the guy slept
around or something right yeah so the
equivalent is like a girl saying are
guys saying well women are horrors
like i think
like people would freak out
no but i thought that that is two
different statements like hold on men
are trash we're on our walls we've i
feel like calling someone trash yeah
that's a
okay that's okay the the wrong word is
understatement but you're saying
someone's trash rap but no that's a
whole completely different thing so i
feel like that's where you know it's not
going to matter you think it's about the
words so you think if they walked around
saying women are trash no one would care
and oh that's a good one um
yeah i wanna i know i'm not gonna lie
yeah i'm not gonna lie you think no one
would care i don't think because the
same way girls be screaming men are just
guys the men don't care if men supposed
to scream women are trash because you
know what i'm not gonna lie i've heard
somebody scream women are trash so i'm
i'm a woman i couldn't you're gonna call
me cool but then if a man was like okay
woman or who is that's when it switches
up so you know what that's what i'm
trying to say is i think it's the
difference in like the words that are
said yeah yeah it just seems like do you
not think because to me i think that
again it's really just about
women or men women can cr women can
criticize men but men can't criticize
women because even if they say something
like like i don't date single moms
people freak out if they say like but a
woman can say he has to make this much
money he has to be this tall
if a man says i don't date fat chicks i
don't date single moms i don't date this
i don't do that people freak out
actually you know what yeah i'll be
wrong yes you've got a point you go you
actually you know you got me that you
got a point because what i've realized
in in society in today's society if a
man if a man wants to come and say
something about a woman for example on
like tip top youtube snap it'll go all
over
and then
if a woman wants to say something about
a man yeah
no one would react type of thing but i
feel like that's because of gender norms
la for la that's cause of gender norms
for example yeah what you just said
women can go around doing stuff but this
it's like men can
hold on woman can do stuff that men
can't do but and then it comes back to
is it double standards type of thing
mm-hmm yeah yeah it kind of is a double
slit yeah it comes back to being a
double standard but i think that has an
effect on men's mental health no yeah no
it does it does so that's let's keep
going in this
important to develop yourself but does
it does it bother you that your audience
is predominantly
male does that isn't isn't that a bit
divisive no i don't think so i mean
it's no more divisive than the fact that
youtube is primarily male and tumblers
female isn't it tumblr is primarily
female
but you're just saying that's the way it
is well it's i'm not saying anything
it's just an observation that that's the
way it is um there's plenty of women
that are watching my lectures and coming
to my talks and buying my books it's
just that the majority of them happen to
be men
uh it's what's in it for the women
though
well what sort of partner do you want
do you want an overgrown child
or do you want someone to contend with
that's going to help you and they also
rely on women have some sort of duty to
sort of help fix the crisis of
masculinity it depends on what they want
no i mean it's exactly exactly how i
laid it out like
women want
deeply want men who are competent and
powerful
and and i don't mean power in in
in them in that they can exert
tyrannical control over others that's
not power that's just corruption
power is competence
and
why in the world would you not want a
competent partner well i i know why
actually you can't dominate a competent
partner so if you want to dominate you
should dominate is that what you're
saying no i'd say women who have had
their relationships impaired with
impaired
their relationships with men
impaired and who are afraid of such
relationships will settle for a weak
partner because they can dominate them
but it's a sub-optimal solution do you
think a lot of women are doing
i think there's a substantial minority
of women who do that and i think it's
very bad for them they're very unhappy
it's very bad for their partners
although their partners get the
advantage of not having to take any
responsibility but what gives you the
right to say that i mean maybe that's
how women want their relationships those
women i mean you're making these vast
generalizations
i'm a clinical psychologist right so
you're saying you've done your research
and women are unhappy dominating men
i didn't say they were unhappy
dominating then i said it was a bad
long-term solution okay you said it was
making them miserable yes it is and it
depends on the time frame i mean there
can be there's intense pleasure in
momentary domination that's why people
do it all the time but it's no formula
for a long-term successful long-term
relationship that's reciprocal right any
long-term relationship is reciprocal
virtually by definition
so
let me put a quote to you from the book
where you say there are whole
disciplines in universities forthrightly
hostile towards men these are the areas
of study dominated by the post-modern
stroke neo-marxist claim that western
culture in particular is an oppressive
structure created by white men to
dominate and exclude women
but then i want to put minorities too
dominating okay
but i want to put to you that here in
the uk for example let's take that as an
example the gender pay gap stands at
just over nine percent
you've got women at the bbc recently
saying that the broadcaster is illegally
paying them less than men to do the same
job you've got only seven women running
the top ftse 100 companies
so it seems to a lot of women that
they're still being dominated and
excluded to quote your words back to you
it does seem that way but multivariate
analysis of the pay gap indicate that it
doesn't exist
but that's just true is it i mean that
that's a gap between median hourly
earnings between men and women but
that's it yeah but there's multiple
reasons for that one of them is gender
but it's not the only reason like if
you're a social scientist worth worth
your salt you never do a univariate
analysis
like you say well women
in aggregate are paid less than men okay
well then we break it down by age we
break it down by occupation we break it
down by interest we break it down by
personality but you're saying basically
it doesn't matter if women aren't
getting to the top because that's what's
skewing that gender pay gap isn't it
you're saying well that's just a factor
not necessarily going to get to the top
no i'm not saying it doesn't matter
either you're saying there are multiple
reasons for it yeah but those reasons
why should women put up with those
reasons
why should women be content i'm not
saying that they should have put up with
it i'm saying that the claim that the
wage gap between men and women is only
due to sex is wrong and it is wrong
there's no doubt about that the
multivariate analysis have been done
multi-varied analysis
i'm saying that nine percent pay gap
exists that's a gap between men and
women i'm not saying why it exists but
it exists now if you're a woman that
seems pretty unfair
you have to say why it exists but do you
agree that it's unfair if you're a woman
not necessarily and on average you're
getting paid nine percent less than a
man that's not fair is it
it depends on what do you think she also
point like i mean i i'm actually curious
to hear why because what the lady said
was that the lady was just asking why
and then he was like
yes cause of gender but that's not the
only reason so i'm thinking why is that
because i'm still trying to find a
reason he's like due to personality and
other things
okay but why are we still getting paid
nine percent less than men
[Music]
okay so he's going to talk a little bit
about why yeah i'm curious i'm curious
to hit this yeah okay
i can give you an example
okay
there's a personality trait known as
agreeableness
agreeable people are compassionate and
polite
and agreeable people get paid less than
dis less agreeable people for the same
job
women are more agreeable than men
again a vast generalization sometimes
that's true but that's right and some
women get paid more than men so you were
saying that by and large women are too
agreeable to get the pay rises now i'm
saying that that's one component of a
multivariate equation that predicts
um salary it accounts for maybe five
percent of the variance something like
that so surely you need about another
twenty about another eighteen factors
one of which is gender and there is
prejudice there's no doubt about that
but it accounts for a much smaller
proportion of the variance in the pay
gap than the radical feminists claim
okay so rather than denying the pay gap
exists which is what you did at the
beginning of this conversation shouldn't
you say to women rather than being
agreeable and not asking for a pay rise
go and ask for a pay right make yourself
disagreeable with your book oh
definitely there's that but i also
didn't deny it existed i denied it it
existed because of gender okay because
i'm very very very
careful with my words
so the pay gap exists you accept that
but you're saying
i mean the pay gap between men and women
exists but you're saying it's not
because of gender it's because women are
too agreeable to ask for pay rises so
one of the reasons okay one of the
reasons so why not get them to ask for a
pay right i've done that
many many times in my career and they
just counseled oh they do it all the
time you can it's so one of the things
that you do as a clinical psychologist
is um assertiveness training so you
might say
often you treat people for anxiety you
treat them for depression
um and you and maybe the next most
common category after that would be
assertiveness training and so i've had
many many women extraordinarily
competent women in my clinical and
consulting practice and we put together
strategies for their career development
that involve continual pushing competing
for higher wages and often tripled their
wages within a five-year period okay so
what do you think now
okay so i'm just gonna run that back so
what he said was
we've got to make uh as women we have to
make ourselves more assertive to our
bosses just to get a pair
is that what he was saying because i'm
trying to
run that back in my head
yeah so it people that are agreeable
don't tend to ask for pay raises okay
because they they tend to agree more
than disagree so disagreeable people
make more money and as a whole men are
more disagreeable women are more
agreeable okay
so that's one of many factors that
contributes to the pay gap
and so a lot of times people will think
just because there's a like a difference
that's because of gender but it's not
necessarily because of gender it's
because of a personality trait
that women tend to have more of so i'll
give you a stat okay yeah cool 60 of
women have never in their life asked for
a raise so it's like so more with 60
and they'll quit their job before they
ask for a raise so how can we blame the
pay gap on men if we keep agreeing to
lower wages
like how can we say it's sexism
when it's us
agreeing to this okay
so okay you got me there however what i
wanna
say is
what if is to do with your boss type of
thing like say for example you're
working hard you're doing all everything
you can right
and then you can't ask your job for a
raise you can't i mean you can't ask
your boss for a raise because he's like
this angry mean person or she is like
this that angry mean person like that
person is just me so you know you can't
ask them for anything well then
then you go find another boss i'll give
you an example i know a lot about
equipment yeah right
and
um in the fall i'll probably have offers
to like manage my channel
and or like let's say and if i if i
picked one of those and i was working
for someone yeah if if they don't treat
me the way i want to be treated i'll
just say screw you i'm talented enough
to go find someone else does that make
sense yeah and that's like sort of the
mentality that more men have where women
are more like comfortable they want to
stay and part of being disagreeable is
like not being afraid to leave
so if you don't have a good boss like
you can pick another one if you're
skilled like especially good workers
like the if you're if you have a unique
set of skills people will pay you no you
got me dead yeah no i hate that one it's
interesting though i don't think a lot
of people i think as women like we're
told our whole lives there's this pay
gap it's because of our gender
no yeah we got we got told that from
when we was young yeah from when we was
what at least 10 mm-hmm at least 10 not
even 10 nine we got told that men get
paid higher from when he was a young age
that one never sat right with me because
i know i was one of them ones i was nine
i was just in a class in primary school
i was going through jobs and then the
teacher was like men always get paid
higher that one day teacher told you
yeah the teacher told us that the
teacher
because it's not true
i'll give you an example another example
modeling men make significantly less
than women in modeling
why aren't we marching the streets for
them that's not fair no yeah but but and
like it's also okay he's gonna talk
about different stuff but like
it's like like it's only when equality
doesn't benefit women then we complain
but when men aren't equal we don't
complain for them
it's like like women get into bars for
free what if there was a place that they
only let men in for free
and women had to pay we would freak out
we wouldn't accept that
you know that's true yeah that is cheap
we would say it's discrimination like
that's open discrimination at bars
imagine imagine if they did that with
like skin color
people would freak out that would be
hell would freeze but with with gender
it's it's okay
isn't that weird yeah yeah no you know
you actually got me thinking like that
is weird you got me thinking you really
got me thinking and we'll have women
only gyms
right like women only spaces women only
gems
but like what if they did that what if
they did that with like race
that would be that'd be terrible
or even men only spaces women always
want to get in them
and like it was yeah like it was um like
like country clubs and [ __ ] used to be
men only and then women were like
protesting and all this stuff
i remember i was in class right and then
i remember
no we were saying i was in a sport class
yeah and then it was it was we were well
i think this was business and sport so
we also know we're also going on a
business out of things about how to
attract more customers and then i think
i must i just to be silly i was like why
can't there be men only james and then
one of my other classmates responded
but would would does there need to be a
men only gender if men know that they
can just work out it's woman's that are
the ones that are scared because of the
um attraction that they're going to get
from most whilst they're working out
from then on i was just that that one
that got me thinking that but being
honest do men need only men gyms
two men need only men gyms yeah if they
want one yeah i don't see why not
i think like men's only some guys just
like i'm sorry but a hot guy he's gonna
get hit on by women too
it's just like most men don't that
doesn't happen to most men but if you're
a super attractive guy you don't think
they have women approaching them at the
gym or trying to flirt with them
i mean i'm checking out the heart guys i
don't know about you
i'm looking i would personally be
working out
but the um
it's just interesting it's like society
just view men it's like a lesser
wait you think society view men as less
yes
i think they they
they say that we view men as more like
right and then i think that's what's
like pushed to us in the media and in
the name because they're like the
oppressive people or whatever yeah then
they're trying to like get even
but i don't think that's what it is
because as women we're empowered from a
young age you're told you can do
anything be anything if you want if
you're the first woman to do something
like
that where
men if they do something it's like oh
he's just a man he's just a white male
like that like i feel like it depends on
what it is you know i agree with you to
an extent but it depends on what it is
for example if it was the first woman to
be a prime minister in a country
then i understand why i should get the
attention because let's take the uk for
example
have we had more male or more female
prime ministers i think we've had more
male i could be wrong
but i think we've had more male 1
so when the first female prime minister
came up i'm sure it wasn't a hype but
the same thing with a dance academy
because if a dance academy that's
dancing is quote unquote for females but
if a male was to open up her dance
academy i'm sure he would get that
attention type of thing so from what you
said i think it honestly it depends on
what
and what it is yeah it depends on what
it is in order for people to get that
type of attention it almost seems like
if a woman's doing a masculine thing and
a man's doing a feminine thing that's
when there's praise that's
what which
i don't know i don't think it should
matter like i genuinely don't think it
it matters it matters how you're doing
the job so but it's just interesting
because you don't really think about
this stuff no because you actually got
me thinking about this stuff like yeah
it really did yeah it's interesting here
can you celebrate associate of course so
do you actually do you agree that you
would be happy
if that pay gap was eliminated
completely because that's all the
radical feminists are saying it would
depend on how it was eradicated and how
the how how the disappearance of it was
measured and you're saying if it's at
the cost of men that's a problem oh
there's all sorts of things that it
could be at the cost of it could even be
at the cost of women's own interests
so because they might not be happy if
they get equal pay
no because it might interfere with other
things that are causing the pay gap that
women are choosing to like having
children
well or choosing careers that actually
happen to be paid less which women do a
lot of but why shouldn't women have the
right to choose not to have children or
the right to choose those demanding they
do they can
yeah that's fine but you're saying that
makes them unhappy by and large i'm
saying that that no i'm not saying that
i'm i and i actually haven't said that
so far you're saying it makes them
miserable no i said that what was making
them miserable was having part was
having weak partners
that makes them miserable right um i
would say that many women around the age
of i would say between 28 and 32 have a
career family crisis that they have to
deal with and i think that's partly
because of the foreshortened time frame
that women have to contend with like
women have to get the major pieces of
their life put together faster than men
which is also partly why men aren't
under so much pressure to grow up so
because for the typical woman
she has to have her career and family in
order
pretty much by the time she's 35
because otherwise the options start to
run out and so that puts a tremendous
amount of stress on women especially at
the end of their 20s i think i take
issue with the idea of the typical woman
because you know all women are different
and that's what i want to just put
another quote to you from the book well
they're different in some ways and the
same in others
okay you say women become more
vulnerable when they have children and
you talk to one of your youtube
interviews about crazy happy sisters
so
simple question is gender equality a
myth in your view is that something
that's just never going to happen
it depends on what you mean by equality
nobody if you mean men and women getting
the same opportunities
fairly people could we could get to a
point where people were treated fairly
or more fairly i mean people are treated
pretty fairly in western culture already
but we can they're really not though are
they i mean otherwise why would there
only be seven women running ftse 100
companies in the uk why why would there
still be a pay gap which we've discussed
why are women at the bbc saying that
they're getting paid illegally less than
men to do the same job that's not fair
let's go to the first question they're
both complicated questions seven seven
women repeat that one there's seven
women running the top ftse 100 companies
in the uk well the first the first
question might be um why would you want
to do that
why would a man want to do it
i know there's a lot of money
there's a certain number of of men
although not that many
who are perfectly willing to sacrifice
virtually all of their life
to the pursuit of a high-end career so
they'll work these are men that are very
intelligent they're usually very very
conscientious they're very driven
they're very high energy they're very
healthy and they're willing to work 70
or 80 hours a week non-stop specialized
at one thing to get to the top so you
say women are just more sensible they
don't want that because it's not an
isolated i'm saying that's part of it
definitely and so i work
you don't think there are barriers in
their way that prevent them getting to
the top there are some barriers yeah
like other like men for example i mean
to get to the top of any organization is
an incredibly competitive enterprise and
the men that you're competing with are
simply not going to roll over and say
please take the position so let me come
back absolutely all out warfare is
gender equality a myth
i don't know what you mean by the
question men and women aren't the same
and they won't be the same that doesn't
mean they can't be treated fairly is
gender equality desirable
if it means equality of outcome then
almost certainly it's undesirable that's
already been demonstrated in scandinavia
because in scandinavia i mean by that
equality of outcome is undesirable well
men and women won't sort themselves into
the same categories if you leave them
alone to do it off their own accord i've
already seen that in scandinavia it's 20
to one female nurses to male something
like that it might not be quite that
extreme and approximately the same male
engineers to female engineers and that's
a consequence of the free choice of men
and women in the societies that have
gone farther than any other societies to
make gender equality the purpose of the
law those are inerraicable differences
you can eradicate them with tremendous
social pressure and tyranny but if you
leave men and women to make their own
choices you will not get equal outcomes
right so you're saying that anyone who
believes in equality whether you call
them feminists call them whatever you
want to call them should basically give
up because it ain't going to happen only
if they're aiming at equality of outcome
so you're saying give people equality
of opportunity that's fine it's not only
fine it's eminently desirable okay so
what'd you think do you understand what
he's saying when he says equality of
outcome versus equality of opportunity
the quality of outcome versus the
equality of opportunity i'm intrigued to
what
he has to say about that
because that that got me i'm trying to
think of what is he
trying to that what's he channel what's
the point that is he trying to make okay
so often times we have two groups and
there's a disparity between them yeah so
let's say an income disparity we assume
it might be something like race gender
something like that but what they don't
take into account is different groups of
people choose different things like i'll
give you an example
all of my brothers are engineers
and the reason part of the reason is
we're german and germans tend to be
engineers so if you look at germans
versus another group of people they're
going to make more money because
engineers make a lot of money and that
culture pushes engineering
and so if you said why aren't they equal
with say like why aren't equally as many
asian guys and at german guys
engineers like people don't pick 50 50
in any group
so men and women is no different
so women tend to pick jobs that pay less
because they want to work in those jobs
and so even if you take away all the
barriers
and let women pick what they want to
pick they're going to make less money
because they pick jobs that pay less
okay does that make sense so a woman
yeah yeah yeah yeah
and like in with the the high paying
crew so my dad makes my dad's very very
successful okay my dad top one percent
earner okay like he he does very well
but i didn't see him for most of my
childhood he worked 80 hours a week my
whole life like that's that's 12 hours
every single day
seven days a week for 20 30 years
women don't want to do that
yeah do you want i don't want to do that
that sounds terrible 12-hour days okay
but what is the job saying though like
what is the job to be working
12 hours a week no no eight hours a week
my dad he opened a software company and
he employed two 200 250 people so like
you have to one know how to manage the
people get them to do what they're
supposed to do like that's that's it's
so much work yeah like i'm starting to
hire people and i see all the problems
that come i can't admit i would never
want a man i would never
i could not manage that many people i
can barely manage two
and and i think
you know like there's just more men that
want to do that because women at some
point we want to have children yeah
and they say it's society that pushes
them i don't think it's society i think
it's it's that is this their choice is
that that's what the woman wants yes
that's their choice and so she's saying
why isn't it equal and he's saying well
it depends what you mean by equality
because if it's do you want it to be 50
men in engineering 50 women in
engineering you would have to force
women to be engineers to do that you
have to put a gun to their head and say
there must be engineers
yeah
is that and have you seen do you do you
know what a quota is so a quote is when
you tell a company you must hire women
is that what is that
yeah i don't know affirmative action
quotas
i think it's it's quotas so it's like
when a company says instead of like
picking who we want to pick we have to
look for a female
and so then you have girls that aren't
as qualified getting jobs that they're
not like that they shouldn't have
because they have to overlook the men
that are more qualified because they
need a girl see i know when you said a
description i understood it but then i i
didn't know that that that was called a
quote but when you said description i
understood yeah brandon
yeah this is man vaguely so girls so
don't so the job says we have to hire a
woman right yes and then girls are
getting well it's usually a company
policy well yeah yes yeah yeah so
then girls are getting the job and
they're not qualified for that
did they still get paid the same as men
because of not because they're not
qualified
i mean i think it depends on the woman
right but sometimes no sometimes they
don't get paid as much but what i'm
saying is like there are there are jobs
my friend works in supply chain okay i
have a friend back home and that's a
very male dominated field and i remember
when she was applying to jobs my me the
guys i was friends with applied for the
same job she did but she got the job
because they need women and so and
that's what all my guy friends would say
because
she wasn't she didn't have the
qualifications that they had
but they picked her because she was a
girl it's not to say she had no
qualifications like she was really smart
she did a good job
but
it's it's the the idea that you're
picking someone based on gender rather
than like what's the qualifications
which i think is wrong like i think it
should always be about the
qualifications it doesn't matter if it's
a woman or a man however that one i
agree i'm not gonna lie to you i agree
on that one yeah i really won't lie i
hands in yeah on that one because yeah
no i'm so sorry i agree on that one i
can't i can't rebut with that one i have
to yeah because with qualifications yeah
it shows that the person knows what
they're doing regardless of their gender
hands down ivy in that one
and it hurts women because then if a
girl is qualified and gets the job they
might think she's not you know what i'm
saying because then everyone just says
maybe she was more qualified but because
of quotas people are going to assume
it's because the company needed a girl
and it hurts us yeah
[Music]
and then why is the company looking for
more women type of thing are they trying
to expand it i don't know are you trying
to
increase the um what's the word called
inclusivity by the chinese yeah yeah
inclusivity yes but to me like i just
don't look at the world like that like i
don't care what you look like
in terms of who i hire right it's like i
care what job you do like i don't think
inclusivity should be a conversation in
hiring because it shouldn't matter like
some things men want to do more some
things women want to do more some
something it's a personal choice
yes
and so and we can't expect that all
industries men and women are going to
pick to do the same yeah that's sushi
like some some things women just like we
don't want to be plumbers
like i don't want to do that we really
don't
bricklayers
yeah cooked cooked i will not be no
no but it's interesting because once you
see start looking at the world like this
every time you see a disparity you don't
automatically think it's about gender
yeah because you don't know
no because this actually generally
opened my eyes like it really did yeah
it's interesting here for individuals
and for society but still women aren't
going to make it that's what you're
really saying depends on your
measurement techniques they're doing
just fine in medicine
in fact there are far more female
physicians than there are male
physicians
there are lots of lots of disciplines
that are absolutely dominated by women
many many disciplines and they're doing
great
so let me put something else to you from
the book you say the introduction of the
equal pay for equal work argument
immediately complicates even salary
comparison beyond practicality for one
simple reason who decides what work is
equal it's not possible so the simple
question is do you believe in equal pay
well i made the argument there it's like
it depends so you don't believe in equal
pay
no i'm just so annoyed
because a lot of people listen to you
she's like not she's dying
no that's what i was thinking because i
would like at the beginning of this
video i'm not i won't lie i actually
sided with her but then the more i'm
watching it it's like wait a minute
you're really not listening
you're not listening she's laid it out
for her so many times yeah
she's still like
like lady
like she's really head butt on and
trying to get her point across because
like i said i'm not gonna lie in the
beginning i was saddened with her i
agreed with what she was saying but then
when i listened to her he was saying you
know
it made sense it really did like
yo
you're actually not listening i'm just
thinking very carefully and i'm hearing
you basically saying women need to just
accept they're never going to make it on
equal terms equal outcomes is what how
you defined it no idea if i was a young
woman watching that i would go well i
might as well just go and play with my
cindy dolls i'd give up trying at school
because i'm not going to get the top job
i want because there's someone sitting
there saying it's not possible
it's going to make you miserable
desirable that's what i said it's a bad
social goal i didn't say that women
shouldn't be striving for the top or
anything like that because i don't
believe that for a second striving for
the top but you're going to put all
those hurdles in their way as has been
in their way for centuries and that's
fine you're saying that's fine no no i
think i really the patriarchal system is
just that's silly i do i think that's
silly i really do i mean look look at
your situation you're hardly
unsuccessful yeah and i have how do you
make it hard to get exactly
good that's okay battling is good this
is almost inevitable but you talk about
men fighting let me just put another
thing to you from the bottom you're
saying you have to battle for a high
quality position
well i notice in your book you talk
about real conversations between men
containing quote and underlying threat
of physicality oh there's no doubt about
that what about real conversations
between women is that something are we
sort of too amenable and reasonable
no it's just that
the domain of physical conflict is sort
of off limits for you well you just said
that i fought to get where i've got yeah
but what does that mean
i don't imagine that you've yeah to some
degree i suspect you're not very
agreeable so that's the thing successful
women i'm not very agreeable right yeah
i don't have that mission it's
confrontation at least and i'm sure it
served your career well successful women
though
basically have to wear the trousers in
your view they have to sort of become
men to succeed is what you're saying
well i've had to fight to succeed
against men certainly masculine traits
are going to be helpful i mean one of
the things i do in in my counseling
practice for example when i'm consulting
with women who are trying to advance
their careers is to teach them how to
negotiate and to and to be able to say
no and to not be easily pushed around
and to be formidable and you need to if
you're going to be successful you need
to be smart conscientious and tough well
here's a radical idea why don't the
bosses adopt some the male bosses shall
we say adopt some female traits so that
women don't have to fight and get their
sharp elbows out for the pay rises it's
just accepted if they're doing the same
job they get the same pay
well i would say partly because it's not
so easy to determine what constitutes
the same job and almost because
arguably
there are still men dominating our
industries our society and therefore
they've dictated the terms for so long
that women have to battle to know that's
not true
it's not true so for example
well i can give you an example very
quickly so i worked with women who
worked in high-powered law firms in
canada for about 15 years and they were
as
competent and put together as anybody
you would ever meet and we were trying
to figure out how to further their
careers
and there was a huge debate in canadian
society at that point that was basically
ran along the same lines as your
argument is that if the law firms didn't
use these masculine criteria then
perhaps women would do better but the
market sets the damn game it's like and
the market is dominated by men it's not
the market is dominated by women they
make 80 of the consumer decisions that's
not the case at all if you're talking
about people who stay at home looking
after children by and large they are
still women so they're going out doing
the shopping but that is changing they
make all these
patients okay so the market is driven by
women not men right okay and if you're a
lawyer they still pay more for the same
sort of goods
that's been proven that men for the you
buy a blue bicycle helmet is going to
cost less than a pink one anyway we'll
come on to that partly because men are
less agreeable
right so so they won't put up with it i
want to ask you
is it not desirable to have some of
those female traits you're talking about
i'd say that's a generalization but
you've used the words female traits is
it not desirable to have some of them at
the top of business i mean maybe they
wouldn't predict a banking crisis they
don't predict success in the workplace
the things that predict success in the
workplace are intelligence and
conscientiousness agreeableness
negatively predicts success in the
workplace
you're saying that women aren't
intelligent enough to run these topics
no i didn't say that at all you said
that
female traits don't predict success but
i didn't say that intelligence wasn't i
didn't say that intelligence and
conscientiousness well you were saying
that female traits just by implication
are not female traits no no i mean
that's very murderous not saying that at
all are women less intelligent than men
no not no they're not no the the data on
that's pretty clear the average iq for a
woman in the average iq for men is
identical there is some debate about the
flatness of the distribution which is
something that james damore pointed out
for example in his memo but there's no
difference at all in general cognitive
ability there's no difference to speak
of in conscientiousness women are a bit
more orderly than men and men are a
little bit more industrious than women
but the difference isn't big i don't
think that averages into any men who
aren't necessarily well of course
but female 1
why are they not feminine treats why are
they not desirable at the top of
feminine traits why are they not
desirable
it's hard to say i'm just laying out the
empirical evidence like we know that we
know the traits that predict success but
we also know because companies by and
large have not been dominated by women
over the centuries we have nothing to
compare it to
it's an experiment true and it could be
the case that if companies modified
their behavior and became more feminine
they would be successful but there's no
evidence for it i'm not neither doubtful
nor non-doubtful there's no evidence why
not give it a go as the radical the
evidence suggests well it's fine if like
if someone wants to start a company and
make it more feminine and compassionate
let's say and caring in its overall
orientation towards its workers and
towards the marketplace then that's a
perfectly reasonable experiment to run
my point is that there is no evidence
that those traits predict success in the
workplace and there's been tried do you
think
was still in the back of my mind of what
he said was
the
um
personality trait that we have
like
because before watching this video i
would allow whatever agree with the
woman and be like okay why don't you
give it a go why can't you make it
more
more for women
and then now looking at this video it's
actually just to do with our
personalities yeah like that's this is
really open my mind
business is ruthless yeah it's about
like it's cutthroat and i don't think
women like where we like to get along
yeah and when you're a boss you can't
you haven't you heard like as like a
boss you can't be too much friends with
the people below you
because they don't respect you yeah like
you have to be able to fire people
that are that are doing a bad job you
have to tell them they're doing a bad
job
yeah and i don't think women i don't do
well with that like it's really hard for
me
i feel like i could
i would i would i'm just such a firm
person yeah but then that's me that's
only one yeah let's talk about the whole
of the woman society the female society
i understand that you you play
basketball yeah have you noticed that
normally
on teams the girls that are captains are
a little bit bitchier
this isn't a shot of uel because i
honestly have no idea who the captains
are no no no because when you said that
you made me think of someone yeah you're
not you we are not you yeah but but you
should have said like
leadership quality yeah and we we use
the word [ __ ] right and the guys might
use the word dick but those tend to be
the people in charge because they have
to be able to say this is what we're
doing this is how we're doing it we're
going to take control like that's i i've
been overlooked even though i've usually
been one of the better ones on teams
i've been on yeah i'm overlooked for
captain positions all the time because
i'm not good at that that's i know what
i'm good at and what i'm not that's just
not a strength of mine
no with me
i feel like
i can be a captain and a leader whatever
you want to call it
but then i'm not old i'm not always
i'm not like i'm not always on that
sometimes you actually just got to be
understanding yeah flat it's not every
day okay this is what we're gonna do
this is how we're gonna do it sometimes
you actually just need to listen to your
teammates not all the time yeah but
sometimes but listen to your teammates
here's the thing that might help in like
a women-oriented like basketball yeah
yeah that's what's gonna say make
yeah compassion that doesn't yeah it's
appreciated
you know but it's it's not going to
increase your bottom line because
everyone's trying to make the most money
possible and compete with each other
businesses yeah that's what that that's
what i was just about to say as well
like it being understanding it works
with females because as somebody
i train with both male and females as
well with females you just gotta be a
bit more understandable when it comes to
men here i can't like me personally my
mom through my mouth moves ruthless when
i'm with boys because if i said
something if i said something and you're
a female yeah you know what i'll be like
mad but i take it back i'm gonna say it
just a little bit
softer you know when it comes to boys my
mouth moves ruthless yeah because if i
said that's what it's got that's what's
going to go then i said that's what's
going to go if you're not arguing with
me the door's over there yeah and that's
that's it's but women can't take that
yeah not all women can take that i
personally can't and then
be let's be honest that's the whole
society can we take that
no no no okay let's my point is that
there is no evidence that those traits
predict success in the workplace and
there's
been tried well that's not that's not
really the case women have been in the
workplace for what at least
ever since i've been around the
representation of women in the workplace
has been about 50 so we've run the
experiment for a fair fairly reasonable
period of time but not you know
certainly not for centuries let me move
on to another debate that's been very
controversial for you um
and this is you got in trouble for
refusing to call trans men and women by
their preferred personal pronouns
no that's not actually true i got in
trouble because i said i would not
follow the compelled speech dictates of
the federal and provincial government i
actually never got in trouble for not
calling anyone anything right so quick
question do you think that trans people
should be called by their pronouns oh
respect yeah do you think the government
should be able to tell you you have to
use those pronouns okay first the
government telling me then
um
then no no that's what he was
fighting because the government made of
law that you had to
call them by their pronouns or the
school or something and he said that
that's wrong if you can't tell me what
to say no because
why is the government passing the law as
to something that doesn't need to be
passed because in terms of
as a person i feel like it's a free
world will you make your own choice
right for example i feel i don't know if
you know these pronouns z zero and i
don't know if i'm saying it wrong guys i
don't offend anyone
please i don't know if anyone offend my
audience yeah but i don't know if you
know the pronouns z zyra and zer for
example if someone's like oh i'm a z
zero zero i won't do it you are good on
that no are you crazy i only call it up
out of respect but if the government
says to quit that then i'm not doing
that if they want me to do like he she
like a transport but i'm sorry you're
giving me whole ass pronouns screw you
i'm sorry like that's rude
sorry that's just me being crazy for no
reason pick hiroshi
no i'm sorry you
for what i love i love the compassion
honestly i really love it like it if he
she fine you're asking me to learn a
whole new pronoun make up a word for you
you're that special i don't go around
changing the english language
i learned these times i only learned
that what just
two months ago like you you're nuts like
i literally think i'll do he she fine
but past that no
no not but i just want to be around you
like
uh
like i said yeah i'll only call you that
pronouns if you want me to but then if
the government is saying it it's a bit
of a
wait a minute right wait a minute that
that's his point so i'm just giving you
context yeah you watch the rest okay
you wouldn't follow the change of law
which was designed not once
discriminating
you cited freedom of speech in that why
should your right to freedom of speech
trump a trans person's
right not to be offended
because in order to be able to think you
have to risk being offensive i mean look
at the conversation you're having right
now
you know like you're certainly willing
to risk offending me in the pursuit of
truth why should you have the right to
do that it's been rather uncomfortable
well i'm i'm very glad i put you on this
part
well i'm going to buy this
you get my point it's like you're you're
doing what you should do which is
digging a bit to see what the hell is
going on and that is what you should do
but you're exercising your freedom of
speech to certainly risk offending me
and that's fine i think more power to
you as far as i'm concerned
except you haven't sat there and
i'm just right i've just tried to work
that out i mean
ha gotcha you have got me you have got
me i'm trying to work that through my
head yeah yeah it took a while took a
while it did yeah it took a while
you have voluntary you have voluntarily
come into the studio and agreed to be
questioned
a trans person in your class has come to
your class and said they want to be
called that's never happened
and i would call them she so you would
so you've kind of changed your channel
no no i said that right from the
beginning what i said at the beginning
was that i was not going to cede the
linguistic territory to radical leftists
regardless of whether or not it was put
in law
that's what i said and then the people
who came after me said oh you must be
transphobic and you'd mistreat a student
in your class it's like i never
mistreated a student in my class i'm not
transphobic and that isn't what i said
well except you've also called trans
campaigners authoritarian haven't you i
mean isn't that cool only in the broader
context of my claims that radical
leftist ideologues are uh authoritarian
which they are you were saying someone
who is trying to work out their gender
identity who may well have struggled
with that had quite a lot of time
struggles
you're comparing them with you know
chairman mao who no just saw the deaths
of millions of people just even if the
activists you know they're trans people
too they have a right to say these
things yeah but they don't have a right
to their whole community compare them to
chairman mao
you know i could pinochet or costa
punisher i mean you know this is grossly
insensitive i didn't compare them to
pinochet well i did compare the
authority he was an authoritarian he was
a right-winger though i was comparing
them to the left-wing totalitarians
and i do believe they are left-wing
totalitarians under mao millions of
people died right i mean there's no
comparison between a mao and a trans
activist is there
why not
because trans activists aren't killing
millions of people
the philosophy that's guiding their
utterances is the same philosophy you
understand what he's talking about
i i kind of got lost there no no i was
listening
no it's okay that part's a little
confusing so basically he's saying that
like like basically what we said earlier
the government can't tell me what to say
yes and if the government starts to say
you must say this then what's stopping
them from taking that further so sure
it's pronouns now but what if it's you
can't talk bad about the president
tomorrow what if it's you like it's very
dangerous to allow the government to
tell you what you can and cannot say and
yeah and that's what he's fighting
against and then people called him a
trait like that he hated trans people
okay just because okay not me personally
but just because somebody else is a one
no cooler trans person by the ziz isaiah
like the other pronouns apart from
hishive yeah i don't think that they're
trans for not doing that yeah because
he'd know you know what he has a point
because
like what you said it was like the
government it's like you want the
government to control what we say
that's very dangerous yeah very and
that's that's how if you look at like
and so they're talking about different
countries where like genocide has
happened yeah and his point is it's the
same type of law
so like in um in north korea they can't
say anything there's like a million
things they can't say and yeah that's
north korea is dangerous yeah and so i
think i don't know exactly what people
they were talking about but i'm assuming
it was something similar um that we're
gonna end the the
reaction there because that's like the
majority of it wow what did you think of
jordan peter said
in the beginning
obviously i came about even reprimand
and i begin i was thinking and i don't
understand what he's trying to say but
then the more i watched him
the more open-minded i became
the fact that he's probably one of the
first no no probably he's actually the
first person that i've seen that has
actually explained
the pay gap
now i can't come over open myself if i
see a dispute yeah i'll be open minded
because the fact that someone has it has
actually displayed the explain their pay
gap and said it's not just cause agenda
and what is true because of what woman's
personality is like it just makes sense
it's kind of it makes you feel a little
bit lied to doesn't it yeah because
there's no way that the people in charge
of feminism and like pushing that
narrative i can't they had to know so it
makes me question why
why are you pushing this when you know
like like there's no way you're pushing
the 75 cents to the dollar thing this
publicly and i've never had anyone show
you this data i just don't believe it
yeah because of all just gender like my
nine year old soft would be so upset
right now because that's what i was told
i was legit nine i was told men get paid
more than females i was only nine that's
crazy i was just nine in school i didn't
know of course i didn't know much about
right that made me upset as a female
that made me upset like i want to get
paid more what the hell yeah and it
makes you angry at men no it really did
for no reason
but in that video i came with an open
mind actually can't be mad at men
anymore because
it's because of women's personalities
not everyone has the hardcore
personality yeah well not every female
sorry has the hardcore personality some
do which is a small minority of us some
don't yeah that's it yeah it's he has a
plan it makes so much sense
and when you start listening to this
language you're gonna see the language
that people will bring it up in other
areas whenever you hear someone talk
about a disparity between two groups
like you have to ask why
and so it's interesting because like
it just makes you look at the world
different doesn't it a little bit no it
does this is gonna make me look at the
world really different now yeah i'm i'm
not going to even be mad at the pick up
no more it is what it is
it is
at the end of the day well thank you so
much for coming honestly i enjoyed it i
really enjoyed today
to have you on again
we'll have to have you on it again you
know what i would love coming back i
would really want to come back because
this was amazing this opened my mind
more and i really hope this opens other
people's minds more as well yeah um well
tell them do you have any social media
you want to plug i mean my instagram is
ofc underscore zero nine in natasha
natasha's fault n-a-t-a-c-h-a
number s
just
that's all that's
i'll link it in the description yeah so
you guys can find it um okay guys don't
forget to subscribe to the channel for
up like this video like
it's free don't forget to subscribe um
and i'll talk to you guys next time bye